dans cette position il existe un seul
moyen de faire échec et mat en deux
coups avec les Blancs je vous laisse
mettre pause si vous voulez chercher par
vous-même alors j'envoie plein qui vont
me dire ah mais c'est super facile celui
de faire fouger cette échec la tour
reprend derrière échec ici c'est mat non
la tour peut se sacrifier on retarde
l'échéance et ses maths seulement en
trois coups d'où on veut résoudre ce
problème en deux coups d'autres peuvent
aussi me dire ok tout reprendre G7 à toi
de jouer tu reprends et cette fois c'est
maths du couloir ta tour est cloué
certes sauf que sur tout reponge S7 ici
les noirs peuvent jouer un petit coup de
pion et là il y a pas match
immédiatement donc ça ne marche pas la
seule façon de mater dans notre position
de départ en deux couches et de jouer le
très astucieux roi G2 afin de libérer la
case pour notre tour en H3 c'est-à-dire
que si les Noirs capture alors tu auras
3 délivre le mat les noirs sont donc
dans une espèce de zouksang si il bouge
leur fou on fait mat comme ça et enfin
si il bouge leur tour alors en G7
donne mate d'ailleurs pourquoi j'ai deux
est la seule case où ça marche